- I brought cards
to do magic tricks.
- [Reggie] Oh, yes!
- [David] Alright, go ahead
and make sure these are.
Just take a look,
it's a regular deck.
- [Reggie] Yep, regular
deck, no magnetic filters.
- [David] Nothing in there?
- Nope.
- Now,
I'm not going to
shuffle or anything.
I want you to pick three
cards, three cards.
- There's one.
Don't show them
to you, obviously.
- [David] Don't show them to me.
- [Jim] Uh oh, not that one.
- [David] Okay,
show them to Jim.
- Yeah. Alright.
- Do you want me to
say them out loud?
- [David] Nope, I don't you
tell me at all. Alright.
Now I want you to place them
anywhere in the deck, alright?
But all three together.
All three together?
- All three together.
- [David] Alright,
tell me when to stop.
Okay.
Alright.
Now I want you to go
ahead and shuffle.
I won't even look, you
can do whatever you want.
- You won't look
at me shuffling?
- Nope.
- [Reggie] That's
pretty intense.
I think we're--
- What's he doing over there?
- Either that or--
- [Jim] What's he doing
over there? He's not--
- [Man] Staring at
one of the posters.
- [Jim] He's just staring.
- [Man] I'm watching
him intently.
He's just staring
at it like this.
- [Jim] Is he using a
mirror to look backwards?
- I'm not seeing anything,
I have no mirror.
- [Jim] His hands, he's
got a hand on a beer.
- Tell me when you're done.
- [Reggie] Alright, I'm done.
- [Man] He's looking
at the fridge now.
- This, and then I'm gonna, I
am gonna do this real quick.
- Oh, wow.
- Okay.
Now, Reggie, we've never
met before, is that correct?
- [Reggie] That's correct.
- And this is not pre-arranged
in any way whatsoever, is it?
- It has not been.
- [David] Okay, we're
going to flap these,
that's the technical parlance,
and you tell me when to stop.
- [Reggie] Okay.
Stop.
- Okay, I'm gonna put
this card down here.
Tell me when to stop.
- [Reggie] Stop.
- Okay, I'm gonna put
this card down here.
Tell me when to stop.
- Stop.
- [David] Okay.
Alright, so the
bottom three cards,
are the ones you
told me to stop.
- Okay.
- I'm going to
put these over here.
- [Reggie] Looking
at them right there.
- [David] Okay.
Tell me when to stop
- [Reggie] Stop.
- Okay.
Tell me when to stop.
- [Reggie] Stop.
- [David] Alright.
And tell me when to stop.
- [Reggie] (laughing) stop.
- [David] (laughing)
okay, we have three more.
I'm gonna put that pile here.
- [Reggie] Okay.
- [David] Alright, Jim.
- [Jim] Yes, sir?
- [David] Tell me when to stop.
- Stop.
- [David] Okay.
Alright, tell me when to stop.
- [Jim] Stop.
- And tell me when to stop.
- These three cards are
going to go over here.
- [Jim] This is my
favorite trick of yours.
- [David] Okay,
gonna put that there.
So we have three,
we all saw this?
- [Paul] Yes.
- Now, is one of your cards
one of these cards?
- [Reggie] (laughing)
- [David] Reggie?
- Eh, I don't quite remember.
- [Paul] What, you don't
remember the cards?
- [David] Jim, is
one of these cards
one of the cards you picked out?
- [Jim] I think so.
- Which one?
- This one.
- [David] Ha ha!
Alright, thank you.
- [Reggie] Was that
"alright" indicating the end?
- What?
- That was pretty good.
- [Reggie] That "alright,"
was it indicating the end?
- [Jim] I haven't seen
that before, that's a.
- [Man] He got your card.
- Pretty good.
- [Paul] I would
say that you guys--
- So you know how to do that--
- [Paul] You guys failed in
the remembering
of the card part.
That is more disturbing.
- Thank god Jim was there.